okay so hear me out this might sound a
little crazy but i don't think doctor
doom's gonna be the villain in the first
fantastic four movie how goes it
everybody i'm red muffler man and as you
can tell i'm not rob see rob's on
vacation this week and so he doesn't
have to record while he's in cancun
i'm filling in for a day for him so
everyone send rob your best wishes but
anywho i was hanging out with rob during
san diego comic con and after the hall h
event i kind of had this idea about the
fantastic four movie and rob even though
he didn't agree with me just said screw
it put it up on the channel see what
happens and you know what
that's exactly what i'm gonna do so
during marvel's hall h presentation at
comic-con folks were losing their minds
they revealed phase five they showed
trailers for guardians 3 ant-man black
panther 2 and
so much
but then
kevin feige also revealed a timeline for
phase 6 which started with fantastic
four and ended with avengers kang
dynasty
and secret wars and that really really
got me thinking so kang is obviously
being set up to be the big baddie that
much is clear the loki series said as
much and the new trailer for ant-man has
him talking
to scott lang but i don't think it's
that simple
you see kang doesn't give me that
big batty vibe that you'd expect from
someone like thanos and honestly i think
he's gonna end up as a red herring
but we'll get to that so phase six
starts with a fantastic four and any
normal person would tell you well yeah
doctor doom is the fantastic four
villain of course he's going to be the
bad guy well are you stupid and i would
have believed you
and then i saw secret wars on that
timeline then i had a thought what if
instead of giving us doctor doom they
give us
the molecule man
so for those of you who don't know who
molecule man is molecule man began life
as a meek man named owen reese who after
losing a fist fight with an atomic
reactor was given the power to control
matter and warp reality and so he
decided to become a super villain and
got stomped by the fantastic four on the
regular and that's that but then secret
wars happened in secret wars molecule
man learned his lack of self-confidence
resulted in him having a mental block
and that limited his powers but with the
help of doctor doom those blocks were
lifted and molecule man goes from your
average d-lister to a universal threat
but the link to secret wars doesn't end
there in secret wars 2 molecule man is a
driving force behind stopping the
beyonder who also happened to be
cosplaying john travolta and then in
fantastic four 318-319 which many
consider to be this kind of unofficial
secret wars 3
he merges with the beyonder to complete
one another and then in secret wars 2015
molecule man served as this binding
force of battle world which was this
amalgamation of different universes
haphazardly stuck together
in every
single story named secret wars the
molecule man is always a driving force
behind the narrative and he's always
depicted as a universal threat but a big
part of his character is
him getting over that initial mental
block getting over his lack of
self-confidence
and i feel the best place to do that is
not only the first mcu fantastic four
movie but the first film in phase six
alright picture the scene the fantastic
four given their origin story
hey future muffler man here so
apparently the day before this video is
supposed to go out kevin feige decided
to announce hey the fantastic four isn't
an origin story also i overwork my
visual effects artists yay
so yeah ignore that bit about this being
an origin story for all intents and
purposes they can just be oh hey they
were doing a science experiment about
the multiverse or something it's fine
i'm i'm killing it on this debut all
right back to it susan johnny ben and
reed are running an experiment which
goes awry and results in the four being
given incredible powers perhaps as a
byproduct of this experiment going awry
a reactor in the building shoots off a
massive surge of radiation
striking mr owen reese as he's doing
some routine maintenance however instead
of killing him he's been given the power
of matter manipulation
weeks later owen would hear the news of
the fantastic four going on a variety of
superhero antics and how they were a
team of bright-eyed scientists
working in the same building he was in
that very night
figuring they were the reason for his
accident he decides that if they're
going to play heroes then he'll simply
play their villain and so the fantastic
four fight molecule man and while he's
easy enough to fight it first as he gets
more and more comfortable with his
powers over the course of the movie the
four are quickly outmatched molly
hillman at this point realizes that he
is far more powerful than he had
initially thought and before he can
truly test out his powers in a way that
can do any real damage the fantastic
four use some sort of mcguffin to put
him down and de-power him so the day
saved everyone loves the fantastic four
and everything's fine right post credits
molecule man is rotting in the raft he's
just sulking in his own misery and then
he's met by none other than dr doom who
says to him rise knave doom requires
your aid
from there doom and owen will work
together behind the scenes
working toward the goal
of stopping kang
then in the 11th hour during kang
dynasty everything is over kang's one
and the earth's mightiest heroes are
bested and then here comes doom and
molecule man who make quick work of kang
allowing doom to take control of the
multiverse
and finally using the power of the
molecule man doom combines the
multiverse into a broken fragmented mess
called battle world and that will lead
into avengers secret wars with doom
serving as the all knowing god king at
least that's how i would probably write
it i think that pays a good amount of
respect to the source material while
also pulling the rug on the audience
since marvel has been working really
hard to set up kang as the big final
boss here but that's all i have to say
feel free to drop a comment if you think
this idea is cool
or if you think i'm a big dummy just so
you know that if you do you cannot hurt
me in any way that matters but i'll be
signing off remember to drop a like and
hit subscribe if you like what we do
here want to thank rob for the
opportunity to hijack the channel and
make my way into all of your brain
spaces for the evening and in the off
chance that you actually like the sound
of my voice i'm on twitter youtube and
twitch as red mufflerman and uh yeah
have a good one everybody take it easy